dozens of protesters are reported dead
in myanmar as junta leaders put on a
show of strength for armed forces day
deaths are being reported across the
country with many in the city of
mandalay
earlier the general warned protesters
they risk being shot in the head and
back
more than 300 people have been killed
since pro-democracy rallies
broke out in february
from kuala lumpur i am joined by
journalist david grunibaum david welcome
to dw
the armed forces day parade is supposed
to honor the myanmar
military's past but it's clear that
today it's being used as a platform to
continue a war on its own people isn't
it
uh there's no question about it that
this is an army at war with its own
people
in myanmar i mean there are reports
credible reports of more than
90 people killed today so we could be
looking at a death toll potentially of
more than 400
total since the military coup was staged
on february
1st so many of these people shot in the
head i mean the warning came on state
media
about the possibility of demonstrators
being shot in the head today well
they've been doing that
for weeks protesters have been getting
shot in the head so many unarmed
civilians
dead at the hands of the country's
security forces this is part of the
military
junta's plan to just terrorize the
civilian population just like myanmar
who doesn't pass have done
well this new junta is doing the same
thing not only with the number of people
that they're killing on the streets and
in their homes
but they're just terrorizing them with
nighttime raids i mean i've spoken to
people in myanmar this week who tell me
they are terrified
every time they hear a knock on the door
and sometimes it's not a knock on the
door sometimes it's the door being
kicked down when security forces raid
you see people who are in custody with
the security forces
wounded people without weapons clearly
in custody
no way to fight back and yet they get
beaten by
the security forces sometimes people get
taken away by the security forces and
they turn up dead the next day
the sunta is just terrorizing the
civilian population
david talks are underway that might lead
to the resistance having its own army
to fight myanmar's military head-on can
you explain how this could work and
where the troops for this resistance
army would come from
sure so the first thing i have to do is
give you a little bit of context on the
country
in the outer reaches of myanmar around
the periphery you've got
ethnic minority states and these ethnic
minority states are tired
of having a highly centralized
government that's dominated by the
majority
ethnic group the burmese and this highly
centralized government being able to
call the shots across the country
and these ethnic minority states they
have long wanted more autonomy and more
say over their own
affairs and there's actually ethnic
armed groups
with weapons here that have been
fighting battles against the myanmar
army
for decades uh to try and give their
respective states more autonomy
well now discussions are underway that
could potentially lead to bringing these
different armed ethnic groups together
into one sort of national resistance
army
now there's roughly two dozen of these
ethernet groups
depending on how many of them you can
get to pull together
and sign on to the sort of national
resistance army you could potentially
be looking at a sort of resistance force
of about a hundred thousand maybe plus
whoever they could recruit from the
civilian population on top of that
they would still be way outnumbered by
the myanmar army which has more than
four hundred thousand
and it's better resourced um but still a
hundred thousand
could still cause a lot of problems for
the myanmar army now i should say
there's still a lot of discussions and a
lot of details that need to be worked
out
before this sort of unified resistance
army could come together
you know the the coup leader min ong
lang
said the army seeks to join hands with
the entire nation to safeguard democracy
that's an exact quote if i recollect
should the international community be
assured by that
the international community clearly
rejects it just like the populate most
of the population inside the country
rejects it i mean somebody going for
democracy
would not allow the army that he's in
charge of
to shoot down so many unarmed civilians
to terrorize the civilian population
it is very clear minong long is out to
protect
the regime the generals of myanmar are
out for the regime and to protect the
fortune that they've amassed over
decades uh through this country's
natural resources to the businesses they
control
while so many of the people in the
population live in poverty these
generals are millionaires
and they're trying to protect their
regime journalists david grunibaum
really appreciate your
insight in all this thank you